let's get some exposure to the
derivatives of some of the most common
functions we're not going to prove them
in this video but at least at least
understand what the derivatives are so
first let's start with the trig
functions if I wanted to take the
derivative with respect to X of sine of
X this is going to be equal to cosine of
X and if you look at their graphs
it'll make intuitive sense once again I
have not proved it here but this is a
good thing to know the derivative of
sine of X is cosine of X now what about
the derivative of cosine of X what about
the derivative with respect to X of
cosine of X well this was going to be
negative sine of X so derivative of sine
is cosine derivative cosine is negative
sine and then finally the derivative the
derivative of tangent of X tangent of X
is equal to is equal to 1 over cosine
squared of X which is equal to the
secant squared secant squared of X once
again these are all very good things to
know now let's talk a little bit about
Exponential's and logarithms so the
derivative and actually this is one of
the coolest was one of the coolest
results and once again speaks to how
cool he is as a number the derivative
with respect to X of e to the X we use a
drumroll for this one this is one of the
coolest things in mathematics the
derivative of e to the X is e to the X
now what does that tell us and I have to
take a little pause here because this is
just so exciting so let me draw a graph
e to the X so that's my y-axis let's say
that this right over here is my x-axis
x-axis so if I have very negative values
of X either to a very negative value
we're approaching 0 and then e to the 0
is 1 so that's going to be 1 right over
there so it's going to look something
like this and then it's an exponential
it's going to go and start going to
start increasing really really really
really really fast so let's say that's
the graph of y is equal to e to the X
the what this tells us is that at any
point so let's say I go right over here
I say when X is equal to 0 e to the 0 is
1 what's the slope of the tangent line
here what's this
with a tangent line here turns out that
is also one amazing if I go to X is
equal to X is equal to one right over
here the function the function evaluated
here gets us e to the one power or just
E and what's the slope of the tangent
line right over here it is also e at any
point right over here the slope of the
tangent line is equal to the value of
the function at that point this is
amazing this is what is so cool about e
anyway that's not the point of this
video this video is to give you a
catalog of all of the derivatives that
you might really need so then finally if
we're thinking about the derivative with
respect to X of the natural log of X of
the natural log of X this is going to be
equal to and this is also fascinating
this is equal to 1 over X or X to the
negative 1 so somehow we have our
natural log has kind of inserted itself
into when you take the derivative as
filling in the gap that the power rule
left vacant which is is there some
function whose derivative is equal to X
to the negative 1 the power rule got
gave us functions whose derivatives
might be X to the negative 2 X to the
negative 3 or X to the squared or X to
the fifth but it left the X to the
negative 1 vacant and it's filled by the
natural log of X now I haven't proved it
here I've just catalogued these for you
and then we can use these in future
videos and we'll prove them in future
videos